also on the agenda today home sexually
this extremism disruption order and it's
already illegal to incite violence in
this country what difference will it
make I think it will make a real
difference we need to deal with the
extremists who are trying to divide us
they're seeking to promote hatred and
intolerance seeking to undermine the
very values that make us the country we
are that make us the great country to
live in those pluralistic values that we
have in our society and our values of
democracy rule of law and order
tolerance of different faiths you know
it's great to live in a country where
people have a right to live how they
choose to live but that brings with it a
responsibility to accept others rights
to live how they choose to live and what
we're talking about in the counter
extremism strategy has a new bill a new
piece of legislation which will
introduce new orders to ban extremists
extremist groups will bring in closure
orders enabling us to deal with premises
where there is this regular promotion of
these extremist values and remember
these X this extremism can lead to
radicalization of Earth young people can
lead to the poisoning of people's minds
such that that can then of course lead
to violence and that could possibly go
as far as closing Moss people's place of
worship what we need to obviously have a
very carefully drafted legislation in
relation to the closure orders but I
think what we're talking about is where
web premises are being used regularly
and consistently for promoting extremist
values for trying to undermine our
society undermine the values that we
share here in the United Kingdom then it
is important that we're able to take
action on those premises but the bill
will be part of a wider strategy
will conclude with in it for example the
program helping isolated communities so
there will be other parts of this
strategy too and also a very positive
promotion of our British values I think
many people feel that we know we share
great values in this country but we
often don't talk about it enough we
don't promote those values enough and I
think it's important that we do very
quickly and secretary any contradiction
between the notion for standing up for
free speech as you say and promoting the
values that you're suggesting no there
isn't
three speech is one of those values that
underlies our society as well it's one
of the important values that we share
and that we want to protect and what
we're talking about here is not about
undermining free speech it's about those
people who are preaching who are
promoting hatred and intolerance who are
seeking to divide us as a society and
who are seeking to undermine values like
the freedom of speech and undermine our
democracy in our law and order